whitney w-a-r-r-e-n-w-h-i-t
n-e-y deputy fire chief clark county
fire department
is that okay it's coming through okay
everybody
okay well again
uh good morning to everyone
i'd like to thank you for attending this
press conference
i have a prepared statement here and
then i'm going to introduce
special agent gorman behind me
but first off i would like to
acknowledge and thank the
men and women of the clark county fire
department
and las vegas fire and rescue who were
here that night battling the fire
under extremely harsh conditions
and the subsequent fires that started
and also i would like to acknowledge las
vegas metropolitan police department
for their help in evacuating during fire
suppression activities and also traffic
control
i would also like to thank las vegas
fire rescue
henderson fire department and the las
vegas metropolitan police department
and our federal partners from atf
in assisting with this investigation
this was an incredibly large fire scene
with a large footprint plus hundreds of
potential leads that needed to be
investigated
for this reason we requested the atf
national response team las vegas fire
rescue and henderson fire department
fire investigators
along with las vegas metropolitan police
department
to assist with the scene processing and
follow up
on the investigative leads the national
response team
will be leaving tomorrow however
the investigation will continue between
ccfd
and the local atf office to identify
the person or persons responsible for
this fire
and complete this investigation to
present a prosecutable case
to the u.s attorney's office with that i
would like to introduce
atf special agent in charge patrick
gorman
he has an announcement regarding this
case thank you
good morning i'm special agent in charge
patrick gorman
for the bureau of alcohol tobacco
firearms and explosives or atf's
san francisco field division on january
18th
the clark county fire department
responded to a fire here
at the eli at fort apache apartment
complex construction site
at 50 55 south at fort apache road
atf special agents responded later to
the scene to provide investigative
support
and assistance as the scene
investigation progressed
the clark county fire department
requested we provide
additional resources and as a result
atf's national
response team or nrt was deployed
the nrt is composed of experienced
special agents
and personnel including certified fire
investigators
forensic mapping specialists accelerant
detection
canine teams fire protection engineers
electrical engineers forensic chemists
and certified explosive specialists
this nrt response provided 25 additional
personnel from around the country
together the clark county fire
department the nrt
and special agents from the san
francisco field divisions las vegas
field offices
have worked diligently to determine the
cause of this fire
a thorough examination of the scene was
conducted
and included documenting the fire scene
as well as searching through and
examining fire debris
in an effort to identify the cause and
origin of the fire
at this time we've concluded our scene
investigation
however atf and our partners are
continuing to investigate
we are following up on leads including
conducting numerous interviews
and reviewing available surveillance
video
after examining the evidence we have
determined the cause of the fire
on january 18th to be incendiary
meaning it was intentionally set and is
an act of arson
protecting the public is at the core of
atf's mission arson is a dangerous act
of violence
posing a significant threat to the
community
the fire caused extensive damage and
could have tragically resulted in
serious injury or loss of life
atf remains committed with our partners
to finding and bringing the perpetrator
of this crime to justice
as a result atf is offering a reward of
up to ten thousand dollars
for information leading to the arrest
and conviction
of the person or persons responsible for
setting this fire
we urge anyone with information
regarding this fire
to immediately contact atf at one
eight fire
atf tips at atf.gov
or through reportit.com
on behalf of atf and our partners i want
to thank the public in advance for any
information or help they can provide us
for this investigation
thank you
uh we'll take limited questions what
we'd like to do is uh
invite everyone uh all the cameras if
you want to get some b-roll we'll
we'll uh answer some individual
questions why don't we get out of the
inclement weather
i don't know if it's gonna rain again
we'll come over here to their atf's
command post
and we'll answer any questions over
there
yes the last name is g o r
m a n first name patrick
p-a-t-r-i-c-k
thank you very much